[موسيقى
] المشكلة الحقيقية للمحيط هي
أننا لا نستطيع أن نرى من
خلال السطح ، لذلك قد يكون هناك
الكثير من الحياة الجميلة الملونة في
الأسفل ومعظم الناس لا يروها
وهذه في الحقيقة مأساة المحيط
لأنه
حتى لو كان كل شيء  ستُمحى الحياة هناك
ولن يراها أحد
ولذا علينا حقًا أن نجعل هذا أكثر
وضوحًا ،
اسمي هويزامان رقيق وأنا
أدرس التنوع البيولوجي البحري في
باتاغونيا التشيلية ،
وآمل حقًا أن أتمكن من المساهمة في
الحفاظ على هذه المنطقة الرائعة  من
العالم
[الموسيقى]
باتاغونيا التشيلية هي نقطة ساخنة للتنوع البيولوجي
مما يعني أن لدينا
تنوعًا بيولوجيًا استثنائيًا حقًا
هنا لقد غطست في مئات الأماكن
ووجدنا ما بين 100 و 200 نوع جديد
نحاول حصر
المنطقة لمعرفة ما يعيش  إليكم كيف
تتغير الأمور مع تغير المناخ ،
نحن هنا في كومالفجارد وهو
مضيق بحري في شمال باتاغونيا
، المنطقة الشاسعة التي يمتد الخط الساحلي فيها حوالي
80000 كيلومتر ،
لذا فهو مرتين حول العالم
وهي عميقة حقًا ، يبلغ عمقها 500 متر ،
لذا فنحن نحتاج حقًا إلى سيارة تنزل
إلى الأسفل لننظر إلى ما يعيش في
الأعماق ، حيث تعني العربة التي يتم تشغيلها عن بُعد ،
إنها في
الأساس روبوت على كابل يمكننا
المناورة به من القارب ويمكنه التسجيل
يمكنه أخذ عينات ولدينا فرصة
لرؤية الحياة حقًا ومراقبتها حتى
عمق 500 متر ،
لذا من الأنواع الجديدة التي وجدناها هناك
نوعان مهمان جدًا حقًا بالنسبة لي
لأنني
أطلقت عليهما اسم أطفالي وهما fabians و fiona cieneumony
أنت تدرك أنه إذا تم تسمية نوع ما على اسمك
تشعر أنك
قريب منه ، فإنك تشعر أنك بحاجة إلى
العناية به وحماية بيئته ،
لقد كنت هنا للغوص لأول مرة في
عام 2003
وعلى مدار 10 سنوات فقط رأيت
أن  تم تقليل وفرة العديد من الأنواع
بمقدار 75
لقد رأينا أن الشعاب المرجانية قد ماتت في حوالي
نصف المضيق
البحري وهذا على الأرجح
تأثير لتأثيرات استزراع السلمون هنا
ولكن أيضًا تغير المناخ وكل هذا
التراكبات وهو  مشكلة
انقراض
الأنواع يمكن عكسها ، فقد ذهب نوع
وباعتباره علماء ، فمن واجبنا أن نخبر
الناس
أن الموقف خطير للغاية بحيث يتعين علينا
التصرف الآن.
آخر البراري على الأرض
ومن المعروف جدًا أنه بصفتي
عالم أحياء
يمكنني المساهمة في جعلها معروفة بشكل أفضل
حتى يفهمها الناس
وفقط إذا فهمها الناس
فسوف يحبونها وفقط إذا كانوا يرغبون في
ذلك ، فسيكونون مهتمين بها  أخبرنا بالحفاظ
عليها
بما تفعله للحفاظ
على صحة الكوكب
للأجيال القادمة ،
أرسل لنا رسائلك على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
باستخدام الهاشتاغ
نداء إلى الأرض